pas les français sont plus grands et
plus gros seins m 62 62 kg et 94 cm de
tour de poitrine voilà les mensurations
de la femme moyenne pour les hommes vous
ajoutez plus d'une dizaine de
centimètres et autant de kilos
la campagne de mensuration danse il ya
trois ans vient de livrer ses secrets
les résultats sont publiés aujourd'hui
au salon du prêt-à-porter vers la fin du
34 du 36 et bingo rni marc felix
silhouette longiligne fantasme de
magazines car 5% des français seulement
entre dans 1,36 pour toutes les autres
désolé la réalité c'est plutôt ça ims
est relancée normalement votre corps va
s'adapter à la matière j'aurais préféré
que ce soit le contraire trop petit trop
grand trop court bref pas à sa taille
on connaît toute la chanson le fasse et
court en longueur ou trop long c'est pas
très bien ajusté ça dépend effectivement
ça peut aller du 40e 44e il faudrait
qu'ils ces lignes tous quoi qui que
l'état y soient sûrs que ce canton prend
1,46 un vrai 43 c'est tout le bon sens
madame c'est que les français n'avaient
pas été mesuré depuis 30 ans alors comme
cette jeune femme
douze mille personnes de tous milieux et
de toute la france ont été photographiés
sous toutes les coutures
résultat notre corps a changé nous avons
grandi fort si les femmes ont pris de la
poitrine et des formes puisque 40%
d'entre elles font tant 44.46 comme
marilyn monroe
phénomène je crois que plus important
notamment pour le bien-aller des
vêtements pour la conception des
vêtements sera l'élargissement de la
taille donc là un tour de taille plus
important donc automatiquement on va re
modifier un petit peu remodelée un petit
peu les détails gérer commercial ou
avoir meilleure aisance au niveau de la
taille
plus grave l'obésité nous guette
influents des hormones sédentarité
alimentation trop riche
près d'un tiers des français sont en
surpoids certains fabricants ont déjà
pris les devants comme ici dans cette
grande surface ou deux nouvelles tailles
ont fait leur apparition à l'américaine
nous avons dû adapter nos collections et
sortir des nouveaux modèles du sein du 3
xl ou civique celle par exemple qui va
jusqu'aux 68 de nouvelles tailles qui au
delà du monde textile vont intéresser
nutritionnistes et diététiciens des
rondeurs mesurer scientifiquement qui
vont peut-être décomplexer les
françaises matraque et dans la publicité
par la dictature de la minceur